- We have hit the moment in the show
when I share something
awesome from social media
you may have missed, you're welcome.
This is What I'm Liking.
(music and crowd cheering)
At only eight years old,
LeLe is a musical force
to be reckoned with.
She's played piano at some of
the most renowned venues out
there, including Carnegie
Hall, not too shabby.
But her favorite performances
aren't on grand stages actually,
they're at her local senior center
or playing virtually for frontline workers
and hospital patients
right here in New York.
Check her out in action.
(piano playing)
(crowd cheering)
Oh my gosh.
(Kelly imitates piano)
I'm like what?
We have LeLe on the line, right now.
Hi LeLe.
(crowd cheering)
- I'm so excited.
- Oh my gosh, first of
all, you look beautiful.
You need to know that, you look stunning.
How long have you been playing?
- I've been playing when I was
only three and a half years old.
I have perfect pitch.
I can remember the melody
and copy it by my hand.
I love playing the piano.
- Oh my Gosh.
I love you.
Oh, so, what do you love
about playing for seniors and patients?
- Because I can make people happy.
I still remember that one day
after I finished my playing
a senior came up to me and
hugged me tightly and said,
"Honey, you made my day.
You are my sunshine."
I saw tears in her eyes and I
knew that it was happy tears.
- Oh my gosh.
LeLe, at some point,
you've got to come in the
studio and you've got to play.
I want to sing with you.
I just want to hang out with you.
You make me so happy.
God, what a gift you are.
Thank you so much, LeLe.
I'm liking your posts right now
and that's not all, our season
long partner, Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
likes to celebrate those
who create fearlessly,
just like you.
So they'll be using their
Frixion Erasable pen to write
you a check for a thousand dollars, LeLe.
(crowd cheering)
Thank you so much, LeLe.